foreign
[Music]
the guy whose voice you hear and a lot
of microcosmos videos this is my face
and this is my office and I'm here to
unbox the base model of the microcosmos
microscope when I first started getting
interested in microscopy it was very
intimidating for me to try and figure
out what microscope to get and so I'm
really happy that we journey to the
microcosmos are able to provide the
thing that we think is the best thing to
get you started and I'm going to put it
on the desk here
you'll see it there it is this is what
it will arrive looking like
the first thing you will find when you
open it up is the manual we built this
manual up from scratch so you would
understand all the different parts of
your microscope how to use it it's doing
your first samples getting ready there's
also a QR code that links to a bunch of
video tutorials that we have and this
also is available as a PDF and all
updated versions will be available at
microcosmos.store and then
there's probably a bunch of ways to do
this but
oh yeah it's upside down now
[Music]
turn it right back inside up
enjoy the journey and share what you
find we do very much want to see your
videos that you take with us I don't
care if it's just some diatom slowly
gliding across the frame I want to see
what you find we also have a submission
form on the website where you can
actually submit your footage to
potentially be used in a microcosmos
video we want to do like clips of what
y'all make then this will slide off if
you give it enough reason to
[Music]
so
half the head
pull out
power cord here there's this which is
our phone mount which is a new version
of the phone mount a little bit of
microscope oil for the Thousand Times
objective
and then
microscope itself this is just a blue
light filter shoved in there will also
be your cover you want to cover your
microscope and you're not using it so
dust doesn't get on the lenses and stuff
hey hello
best part of buying something is taking
all the little things off of it so
you've got
tissue paper covering up light source
down there a little tissue paper
in this space for safety
and then a little tissue paper on the
stage that's what that's called
twist this little guy
and you can pop this off
and then
slide this in here
and then twist it back in so it doesn't
fall out
dude take out these little guys don't
need those
because your eyepiece is going there now
remember eyepieces are always loose so
do not turn your microscope upside down
the eyepiece will come out and fall onto
the ground and a little switch
light is on
I'm seeing a bunch of magnified nothing
now this is just magnified light so
there's a bunch of ways to control your
microscope you've got the amount of
light that's coming out of the light
source and that's adjustable here these
here are your focus knobs the big one is
you know big Focus the small one is more
fine focused there's this little thing
that actually collects the light and
focuses it on to the slide that's called
the condenser and you can move it up and
down and that affects how the light hits
the slide there's also a diaphragm on
the condenser a little Wiggly uh piece
of metal that will bring the light sort
of more into a point which can affect
how it looks basically if you play
around with it you'll start to see what
I mean and then on this side this
actually moves the stage around so that
you can look around the slide or follow
any Critters that are running around and
that is the thing you'll get better at
fastest is what I've found is like when
I first started I was like everything's
backwards and everything's so confusing
and then after using it for a little
while
um I got very good at it like not as
good as James but good this is our phone
mount that will come with with a
separate Little Instruction Manual
there's also instructions in the guide
for how to use the phone mount now as
you put your eyes on a microscope you'll
see that there's a pretty small point of
light as you approach it and it's easier
with your own head to get your eyes into
the exact same space because you've been
moving your head around for your whole
life it's takes some time after you
clamp this on here to get the right lens
of your camera focused on the right
point of light so it's a little fiddly
but you fiddle around for a while and
then you're able to do it and I actually
find that it can be more comfortable to
be using the phone mount for long
periods of time because I'm just looking
at the screen rather than sort of
hunching into the microscope so now
we're going to use the microscope as
intended we I'm going to set up my
camera to be in here and we have our
prepared Anatomy slides which are also
available at microcosmos.store and the
box is so cool so this goes on here
clamps on so we're lining up the mount
with right kind of flush with the
eyepiece so you can see that in here
basically on the same plane as the IPS
and then I'm gonna get this boy in here
which is going to take a while because I
got a big phone now with my phone
because I got a big phone I have to
clamp low down so that I can actually
get the lens up to where the hole is I
slide that on there now first I gotta
set to my make sure I'm set to my double
lens
my 2x I use procam to to do this because
otherwise Apple will mess with you
because it's trying to fix everything
all right now I've got my
sort of little circle right in the
middle and I'm going to try and clamp it
there it is
beautiful and then I'm going to zoom in
and then I don't know what this is going
to be some loose connective tissue my
favorite kind of connective tissue oh
I'm seeing some pink
let's try and focus focus focus
hey oh gross this isn't this isn't the
sexiest of uh
objects to observe ciliated epithelium
great I actually do want to see some
ciliated epithelium now that I'm
thinking about it
[Music]
some beautiful cells here to work with
see all those nuclei in there so this is
all stained so it looks extra good now
we also have uh plan objectives
available so slightly higher quality
lenses which you can get a set of all
four to replace all the ones you have if
you have the base model and want to
upgrade we also have the 20x and the 60x
available separately if you just want to
get those one one or both of those on
their own I've just put in a lymph node
oh yeah hello
my gosh boy I tell you what I know
nothing about histology this is not my
area of expertise now also on the bottom
of our microscope there is a filter tray
you can put that blue light filter that
comes with a microscope or we have a set
of various filters that do various
things and reinberg filters that will
change the color of an image so without
the filter and then we're going to slide
the filter in place and see what happens
uh yeah see there you get like a dark
Field Effect which on Anatomy slide is
not like the greatest thing because it's
been dyed for like a specific purpose
but
with your microbes at your pond locally
looks fantastic now the thing to note is
when we're saying like 40x or 20x or 60x
when it comes to the objectives that's
going to be multiplied by 10 because
each one of these eyepieces also is a
10x so a 40x is actually 400 times
magnification because it's got the 40
times the 10 of the eyepieces there's a
fair bit to know about microscopy but
I'll tell you what as soon as you start
to do it it becomes you like have all of
this incentive to learn and uh and then
suddenly you wake up one day and you
know the difference between a
dinoflagellate and a rotifer
which
if you watch this show you're probably
already there see it's time to take the
next step it started on your own journey
into the micro Cosmos with this
beautiful object that I love having in
my office but this one's not for me it's
for you we're gonna pack it back up I'm
gonna sign the instruction manual for
you this is the base model you can also
get an upgraded version that has the
plan objectives which are higher quality
Optics already installed on the
microscope that is also available at
microcosmos.store as I always say at the
end of these episodes thank you for
coming on this journey with us I really
am grateful it's a very enriching part
of my life to be a part of this Channel
and also to have a deeper relationship
with that part of our world that is so
invisible to us but is always out there
and I hope very much that we can
continue inviting people into that world
through our videos but also through this
microscope and if you capture something
that you would like to share with us we
again have that form on
microcosmos.store from all of us here at
Journey to the microcosmos including
sitting right there filming me in my
office thank you so much for your
support and your interest in this
bizarre world that we all get to inhabit
[Music]